So now that we've created our empty hash table, the next
steps are to figure out how to do lookups as well
as adds. Both lookups and adds depend on the same first
step. We need to find the right bucket, so that's what
we'll do next. So remember the idea for a hash table,
so we have a list of buckets, each bucket is a
list of entries, and each entry is a key, and the
list of values. So regardless of whether we want to do lookups and
added, and find the value associated with the word, or if we
want to do add and add a new value associated with a word.
The first thing we always have to do is find the right bucket.
So if you find the right bucket if we're doing a lookup, the
next thing we're going to do is need to look through all the entries
in that bucket to find if there's one that matches the key word.
If we're doing add, we also need to start by finding the right
bucket. Then we're going to look through and see if that word already exists.
If it doesn't exist, we can add a new word
and we'll have a new entry, with that word and that
value. So both of those depend on first being able to
find the right bucket, so we'll do that once and be
able to reuse that code in both lookup and add.
So our goal is to define a procedure, and we'll call
it hashtable_get_bucket, and it'll take two inputs. So it'll take a
hashtable, and a keyword, and it will output the bucket where
that keyword could occur. We don't know yet whether
that keyword's actually in the table. It might be somewhere
in that bucket. It might not. But the important
thing that hashtable_get_bucket should do, is find the bucket. One
function that will be useful for doing that is
the hash_string procedure that you defined earlier. And hash_string takes
two inputs. It takes a string, which is the
keyword, and it took a size, the number of buckets,
and it outputs the number which is the index
of that bucket. There's a bit of a mismatch
here that you'll have to think about to define
hashtable_get_bucket. That hash_string, the input is the size, the
number of buckets, it's a number. The two inputs
to hashtable_get_bucket are just the hashtable and a keyword.
So you need to also figure out how to
get the size of the hashtable to pass into hash_string.
And if you remember the structure of the hashtable, you
should be able to figure out how to do that.
Remember our hashtable is a list of buckets, so the
value that we want to pass in to the hash_string is the
size of that hashtable, the number of elements in the
list of buckets, that is the hash table. So see if
you can define hashtable_get_bucket, and as a hint, you can
do the whole definition with a very small amount of code.
It should only take one line to do this.